I worked for my dad's liquor store and
he never really paid me a lot of money
but I was saving money like crazy I was
making 50 000 a year and I was saving 10
000 a year because I didn't buy [__] I
was just working and saving and all
those savings is what let me invest into
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr stock smart
people realize investing is a good way
to go versus just savings but I always
have a nest egg you have to have a rainy
day fund just in case things go poorly
and I think one of the biggest issues in
the world right now for 20 to 30 year
olds is they don't save everyone's
buying dumb [__] to look cool on social
media and then when a rainy day happens
they're panicking and so I think you got
to find your balance in the past you
predicted to come up of the new forms of
media particularly short form video I've
seen in Tick Tock Instagram YouTube so
looking forward into the future how do
you predicts video it will be consumed
and how can content creators at the
moment take advantage of that new wave
code content creators need to focus on
what's free right because I also thought
that long form was going to do well when
I saw how streaming was playing out many
people in this room know that they've
watched five straight episodes of
something on Netflix or Hulu right and
so like long forms doing great like I
watched all of Wednesday
atoms in like one evening you know and
so I think that creators need to focus
on the platforms that are free it's not
easy to get on Netflix or in Hulu right
meanwhile you can make tick tocks and
nobody can stop you and you can become
anybody right and so I think that long
and short form will continue to grow
there'll be new platforms there'll be
decentralized social networks built on
the blockchain there'll be new platforms
just like Tick Tock and Snapchat and
Instagram have come in the last decade
there'll be more and there'll be more
long forms there'll be more and more
streaming there's something called fast
channels
um
so I think there's a lot brewing in
media and I think for everyone here it's
about self-awareness of like what medium
works for you including some people in
here are great writers and don't want to
be on camera and there's opportunities
to transcribe that writing into voice
activated pieces of content so the world
is wide open every kid in this class has
an unbelievable opportunity if they have
self-awareness of how they best create
and if they have understanding of the
free platforms and how to get the most
awareness and then ultimately Talent
awesome thank you so much
here's the word thank you brother
all right who wants to go next hello I
understand that you're invested in like
a lot of different like things you
believe in like saving money at all or
do you think that it's better to have
all your money invested at all times
so the only reason I was able to what
was your name brother
Jacob so check this out this right here
do you see it
so that's Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
stock
those were the first three companies I
invested in so I got much worse at
investing after I started
um
what's crazy about this brother was from
22 to 34 I worked for my dad's liquor
store and he never really paid me a lot
of money because it was like immigrant
family business life so I never got paid
a lot of money but I was saving money
like crazy like I was making 50 000 a
year and I was saving 10 000 a year
because I didn't buy [__] I was just
working and saving and all those savings
is what let me invest into this
so I think it's it's a mix I invest a
lot smart people realize that are
financially Savvy realize investing is a
good way to go versus just savings but I
always have a nest egg I think you got
to find your own balance you have to
have a rainy day fund just in case
things go poorly and I think one of the
biggest issues in the world right now
for 20 to 30 year olds is they don't
save they buy a lot of dumb [__]
you know and so everyone's buying dumb
[__] to look cool on social media and
then when a rainy day happens they're
panicking and so I think you got to find
your balance bro
do you think uh the future of blockchain
Technologies and how can a high school
student like me get involved and try and
make money off of it what's your name
no no I yeah I think blockchain's
massive especially with AI coming does
everybody here raise your hand if you
know what I'm about to say by show of
hands how many of you know what deep
fake videos are
right so look like a probably about half
the class and you guys are youngsters so
one of the craziest things that's
Brewing is deep fake videos like as soon
as we hang up here during class like
Google it if you guys are allowed to
have your phone on you you have to like
really know this there's going to be an
incredible need Noah for the blockchain
because we're gonna need to know proof
of Providence because in about three
years everybody in here will know what
deep fakes are and like it's the biggest
thing that's brewing in the world which
is you can make videos now
of people talking that they didn't
really actually say it it's all AI
generated oh most of you should have
heard about the Drake and weekend song
that was made right by show of hands how
many people know about the fake Drake
there we go so that's where this shit's
going
it's gonna come to video so like
literally there's gonna be videos on me
on Tick Tock in a year saying [__] that
I didn't actually say
and that's going to throw the world into
a spin and I think the blockchain is
going to be a huge factor in proving
that so of course as you know know there
was no chaos of last year's nft spring
but that was a lot of speculation that's
not the place to quote unquote look to
make money getting educated on AI and
getting educated on blockchain
technology and then seeing what's
interesting to you and becoming good at
it that's the big opportunity for you
awesome thanks so much got you bro oh hi
I'm a lead thank you how are you
I'm good how are you doing so good
um do you know I know you like
blockchain technology but would you is
it better to invest in blockchain or
invest like the stock market like which
is better definitely the stock market if
you're talking about nfts right now
because there's so much speculation in
cryptocurrencies and nfts 99 of them are
going to go to zero
so now they'll be
some incredible opportunities in that
one percent but the amount of time and
effort that someone has to put into
being educated there the number one
thing for everybody here who's thinking
about investing even a small amount of
money invest in something you know like
even if it's a brand like one of the
best pieces of advice that I think you
can still screw up but is universally
strong is for especially kids or people
in their early 20s invest in a brand
and a business that you actually love
right like there was a lot of kids that
did really well with like Lululemon and
did really well with like Netflix and
Tesla over the last decade because they
knew it they understood it and so the
number one you know whether it's
blockchain whether it's the stock market
whether there's real estate whether it's
art whether it's Collectibles like
sneakers and sports cards
all of you should remember this is stuff
I wish I got taught in school when I was
growing up invest in stuff you know
so many people are just investing in a
cryptocurrency or an nft because they
heard someone else say it that's silly
invest in things you know hi
um I was wondering like with all the new
VR stuff how like it's becoming the new
world how do you think that's going to
affect social media and influencers
today
it's a good question I think that
VR is inevitable
like especially for people that are as
young as you like
you guys are going to live in a VR World
it might take another 15 years for it to
get to like real scale but it's going to
affect everything if you know think
about how much this affected the world
and this is like the halfway point
between real life and virtual I think
there'll be all new influencers because
of it but even more importantly like
when all of you are 40 and 35 you may be
sitting in VR for five six seven eight
hours a day and that is
very clear to me as a possibility in two
decades so it's going to change
everything it's going to change the way
people travel it's going to change where
people live
you're gonna be able to live anywhere
you want because meetings are not just
going to be on Zoom like this anymore
it's going to feel like you're actually
there so when why do you even have to be
there it's going to change absolutely
everything it's going to change the
landscape of influencers businesses
politics Society dating and everything
else you can think of
thank you you're welcome so
so like you put yourself out there in
the world you post on social media but
like tons of people like every single
one of our parents like they work their
own businesses but like they don't
promote themselves put themselves out
there as much do you believe it's like
beneficial and like people are like dumb
for not doing that or what is your take
on like how it's a good question
I think it's a great question I think
it's a self-awareness game similar to
what I said earlier I don't think it's
dumb not to if you're not capable and
you don't want to and you want to be
overly private and you're introverted
and you don't want to deal with you know
it's all fun and games that I put myself
out there but there's a lot of baggage
that comes along with it right I'm sure
you know people say nasty things people
get into your business privacy so
no I think it's a personal thing do I
think it's beneficial if you're good it
is
you know like if I was not right about a
lot of stuff it wouldn't be good you
know like you have to be good uh so I
think it's a personal journey I don't
think it's a requirement but I do think
it's an opportunity and I think for a
lot of people that do enjoy you know
you know I didn't realize until I
started doing what I'm doing how much I
would have loved being a teacher like
you're a great teacher here I didn't
even know that but I've learned it
through this journey of how much I enjoy
it and so
you know I think if someone's willing to
go there it can lead to a lot of great
things I didn't know that I would love
public speaking I was 34 years old the
first time I gave a public speech
didn't even cross my mind that I think I
got it as a matter of fact here's some
good fun school stuff I don't know if I
can find it where's my report card
um I got a D in speech in high school
right so like there was no indication
that I was gonna be good at it
um and now I love it and so yeah I think
I think it's worth putting yourself out
there if you're if you have a good
understanding that it works for you but
for a lot of people in this classroom
and your parents too introverted too not
interested in dealing with getting made
fun of or getting talked crappy to and
don't want to be bothered in public and
I think that's absolutely right for
certain people and so you just gotta
find your own way hi Gary thank you for
coming I'm David
um we're talking a lot about change
um with technology now especially chat
gbt yeah I just want we thought the
change is good for society or bad for
yourself both
like like every big thing that has ever
happened there's gonna be good and bad
because there's good and bad humans
so
you know some people who have great
intent are going to do incredible things
with this brother and like life's gonna
be so much better like we're all gonna
use our Alexa and our Google home to do
things in two seconds to take time
you know I think I think school systems
are really taking the wrong approach
with chat GPT
you know they go scared and they ban it
and like meanwhile what are you gonna do
when you're 23 you're going to write it
yourself of course not the technology
exists
schools are like forcing kids to still
ride horses when the car was invented
but on the flip side these deep fakes
brother are going to lead to a lot of
problems
like when you are going through your
screen you know your speed and you see
LeBron James saying something you know
how it is now we're all like two seconds
and we believe it to be true
so we're going to have to go through
that and some people can have ill intent
to cause chaos and upheaval and so you
know I think it'll be good and bad but I
do think good in the end because humans
have proven that we can take challenging
things and make them good like humans
are capable of so much destruction and
as much bad stuff as happens it's still
a tiny percentage a tiny tiny tiny tiny
tiny tiny tiny percentage of how we
interact with each other every day and
so I believe in the human spirit I
Believe in Us I think we'll have some
bumps in the road on all new
technologies but I think in the end
they'll be all right
thank you
I'm Ariella
um I was wondering if you think but
college is going to be necessary with
all with everything coming out like VR
AI tragic I do think students are going
to handle in college
I think a lot less
than my era when I was in high school if
you didn't go to college you were
considered like
the worst like like completely incapable
of surviving in life I think parents are
starting to have more thoughtful
conversations kids are starting to have
more thoughtful conversations
look I think for a lot of people in this
classroom college is right you know they
are comfortable in a more structured
environment they know the systems
there's kids in here we all know this
some of you are envious of some of the
kids in this class that don't try it all
and still get A's and B's because they
just have natural talents and they
understand the system right and for a
lot of those people college is right
because they'll go to a good school that
will set up a good job and that's how
they'll live their lives College was not
right for me and because I'm too outside
the box and I think it's cool that
Society over the next 30 Years will not
put pressure on 18 year olds to have to
go there especially if they're
collecting debt
my biggest thing always about colleges
for a kid that it's not right for to be
forced by their parents and society and
their teachers to go to college and
collect debt was a disaster for a lot of
you you might be fortunate where your
parents will pay for it or your talents
in sports or academics will pay for it
but if College isn't right for you and
you take on debt it stinks and it's
going to become more and more obvious
and so I think it's cool that in 10
years only 70 percent of this class is
going to go to college instead of 100 20
years ago
uh and right before we run out of time
last question if you could you know go
back and talk to your 16 year old self
you know what piece of advice would you
give yourself
the concept I have of being nice to
every one of my classmates regardless of
what it meant to my own popularity was a
good strategy because
I really believe that how you treat
people ends up really impacting your
life
and so I I know it's corny but it's
[__] true like I would have told the
16 year old me like you've got this
figured out double down on it be nice to
everyone it's going to pay dividends and
I would tell my 16 year old self that
you're right like college is not right
for you like it is for kenosowski one of
the best students in my high school and
that means you're gonna have to work and
that means you're gonna have to work a
lot to like make your way through the
world and you can either figure out
academics or you can figure out work
ethic and following your natural talents
and I did the ladder and it worked out
for me but a lot of you know one thing I
caution everyone here like unlike when I
was your age entrepreneurship is cool
now right and I know that means for a
lot of you that you want to do it just
be self-aware entrepreneurship might not
be right for you but you might be right
to be the number two or three or four
for an entrepreneur and that could be
huge final point please my friends like
I want you to be happy you have to know
yourself not what your parents want not
what your teachers want and not even
what you you know I know that you want
to be a rapper or an entrepreneur or an
influencer or a celebrity or an athlete
I get it but you have to be self-aware
like I wanted to be a Jets player but by
16 I realized I was more likely to own
the Jets than to play for them and
that's worked out for me
awesome all right Gary thank you so much
again for doing this we really
appreciate it cheers everyone love you
guys
[Music]